insert joke no you want to talk about
epic masterpiece then this is the film
to talk about I truly loved this movie
this movie made me want to read the
Bible not the written [ __ ] the comic
book Bible I can't understand what the
[ __ ] most of the Bible is even if you're
an atheist you will enjoy the hell out
of this movie and if you're Christian or
Jewish you're gonna have an orgasm full
of biblical proportions
buy your soda pop get your butter
refilled popcorn raise your cholesterol
get ready to enjoy this beautifully
haunting emotionally captivating one
hell of a movie experience thingy first
off I love the reimagining of the Noah
story I've read the Noah story before or
actually I haven't I've you know watched
a bunch of children's movies Manjeet and
start seeing a lot of different
interpretations I know the basic premise
of how the story goes yet the film that
managed to like added a lot of stuff
such as the watchers the fallen angels
which added such great substance to the
film remember those like talking trees
in Lord of the Rings
they're kind of like that but actually
interesting it managed to take this
story to more of a fantasy world yet
remain true to the darkness of that time
it felt like a fantasy but through the
character depictions it felt very
authentic the cinematography is
absolutely excellent just some of the
most beautiful shots you'll ever see
combined with the excellent editing oh
my god it's just an amazing film you
know a lot of books get adapt it into
movies now this movies better than the
Bible I'm around many people I just
pissed off by saying that this movies
from director Darren Aronofsky so I went
into this film going this is gonna be
the most depressing Noah movie ever made
and was it you bet yeah there's also
super intense really dark really scary
but it has this like incredible heart to
it Darren he did an excellent job
I call him Darren because sometimes the
sucker is there he knew how to put
together a truly visual experience yet
generates so much emotion throughout
because he really seems to understand
what these people
have been like at that time which just
seems horrible I would not have wanted
to live back that if I live at that time
and her there is a flood coming
I'd be like bring on the [ __ ] flood
and throw some soap in the flood because
this evilness needs to be cleansed I'd
rather die than hang out with people
like Ray Winstone I mean that even today
in modern days Raymond studies like it's
scary Russell Crowe as Noah it's been a
while since I've seen a mind-blowing
performance by Russell Crowe not since
late mr. raw has he been this
mind-blowing Wow
the jokes about Russell I gotta say in
our letters they'll [ __ ] funny it's
just one of those performances where he
just transforms so much into the rule
that it's like he's not even acting he's
just being good he does a great job and
he has like three different hairstyles
in this movie and he pulls them all off
great nervous pubic hair changed over
time and Noah she goes down darker paths
and we've never seen him go before it
actually makes sense what he chose to do
that you know Russell Crowe isn't
virtuosity with Denzel Washington
classic Jennifer Connelly as Noah's
hot-ass wife consider wasel's she blew
me away with the performance - not since
that dildo lesbian scene in requiem for
a dream have I been this impressed
she is like totally 100% believable her
role as a support for Noah the weight
that she has to carry it's just so good
there were times yet to get really
emotional where I even almost cry almost
not a [ __ ] Ray Winstone as villain we
got his [ __ ] in Ray Winstone he's
like the master of playing bad guys I
would never want to meet this guy in
real life cuz I had feelings just gonna
stab me at one point he's wonderful in
the Royal you get where he's coming from
he's not some two-dimensional villain
occasionally he brings up good arguments
all the time he's just scary as [ __ ]
like [ __ ] has never been this scary
before I'm sure he saw Ray Winstone [ __ ]
that [ __ ] would be 10 times more scary
Emma Watson as one of Noah's daughters
really don't remember names that well
she plays a woman who due to some
unfortunate events cannot conceive a
child
aka back then birth control but she
really wants to give a family for Noah's
hot ass song by the way they're not like
blood-related her and the son did you
know it was like brought into the family
I mean even if she was come on the world
was wiped out incest had to be done I
mean the world was gone and all that was
left was Noah's family so next time
you're [ __ ] a girl
I want you to think somehow I'm related
to this woman Emma Watson gives a really
powerful performance so longing for
something more the inner shame she feels
for not being able to provide a family
it was great great performance not a not
a great situation to be in she's so hot
damn I want my penis to be involved with
her somewhere logan lerman as one of
those other kids really don't remember a
ham ham ham and cheese something like
that he's great in the role I thought he
was really British he's that kind of son
who's like dad kind of disagree with you
want a few things you [ __ ] I mean
he's kind of a [ __ ] at times I wanted
two purses Jackson that doesn't make any
sense
as far as the acting goes another
standout job the visuals are incredible
truly astonishing [ __ ] my only complaint
is that sometimes the animals looked a
little too computer-generated but [ __ ]
it there's like a billion animals in
this film I don't accept all them to
look great the production design is top
[ __ ] knotch
like I said as an ironic feel of fantasy
yet feels more realistic than any Noah's
story ever told this is not the best
Noah film I've ever seen way better than
that john-boy NVC piece of [ __ ] that I
saw when I was young let me get oh no
wait the score this score is [ __ ]
amazing cinematic music at its best I
would love to have sex with that music
in the background and then I provide my
flood that supposed to be the orgasm
joke but somehow it sounds like a golden
shower joke yeah acting writing
directing cinematography production
design visual Sisko
almost seen Emma Watson's tits that is
the main reason to watch this movie
that's all incredible well let me get
straight to the point here oh no I gotta
say no I got it super duper right
alright guys thanks for checking on
review for Noah once you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell me which
country would you want to flood you
racist and if you want to see more
episodes the straight to the point
last night at least you go and get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go and upload on this but about my
dick to subscribe that's right the dick
let me say something about this little
Ark every time a woman's eyes flood they
want to escape on this ship correct
I've [ __ ] a lot of women two of every
kind of woman
go to fitness but if I might take this
subscribe that's right the dick let me
tell you something about this little
Ryan
he is [ __ ] two of every animal